hello and welcome to the new world
review your source for everything anime
and manga so long as you know that anime
and/or manga is hunter hunter that is
and today we're going to be looking into
a sector of characters that I have
somewhat neglected to delve into in my
coverage of the succession war arc as
well as graded discussions about the
Dark Continent and to be fair it's
because they have been relegated mostly
to the background for now however they
are undeniably being set up to play a
huge role in the future so it's time to
catch up with what's going down on the
side of Jing and parastone now these two
figures are going into the saga with
quite a history coming right off the
back of the 13th hunter chairman
election up at the time both King and
parastone were members of the zodiac
holding the code names of boar and rat
respectively furthermore in addition to
this parastone was also the
vice-chairman of the hunter Association
who had been gradually undermining the
entire organization leading to this
climax of he and Jing engaging in mental
combat in order to decide who the next
chairman would be following the death of
Isaac natural now the interesting thing
about Jing in parastone is that I
actually have a fair bit in common
they're both wildly intelligent
infinitely ambitious and in this
particular case both heavily disliked by
the hunter Association a large Jing
because he's quite allowed in volatile
fellow whilst parastone is a very
double-faced manipulative type and most
of the support that he did end up
garnering was due to people that he had
directly planted and despite their
differing motivations parastone and Jing
actually think on a very similar
wavelength capable of perceiving
generating and implementing a wide array
of out-of-the-box ideas that has no
doubt assisted both of them in reaching
the positions of prominence that they
enjoy within the series today whilst the
two of them also take great pleasure in
treating rather serious matters like
games and in each other
Jing in Paris did see something of a
kindred spirit or at the very least a
fun individual guarantee to make any
situation that much more interesting and
you know probably the biggest difference
one could really point to between Power
Stone and Jing is a Paris tone is an
awfully patient man more than willing to
weather any situation incrementally
building towards his goal with a
laser-like focus meanwhile Jing enjoys
the same sort of games however he gets
bored very easily with his attention
waning and scampering off elsewhere and
that became very apparent during the
election with Jing being eliminated
fairly early on in proceedings while
spera stone was patiently able to
position himself to win the election and
yes it should also be said that Jing
didn't just give up in fact his ultimate
plan was to manipulate Leora into taking
the victory not that any of this
mattered
anyway in the end anyway because they re
are willing crushed his bid and
parastone despite winning the election
by default immediately resigned as
chairman because you know he's Harriston
and he does stuff like that
I guess just briefly I should say that
the motives of parastone are very much
shrouded in mystery I mean it could
really be as simple as something along
the lines of being bored and goading
people into playing with him which he
definitely engages in and in fact he
very much gets off on the idea of other
people hating him however his motives
could also be an order of magnitude more
complex as it would seem that the entire
reason why Paris Tim became a hunter in
the first place was in service of an
expedition to the dark continent and now
this also brings up the motives of Jing
who is much clearer having revealed that
his current ambition is to travel to the
Dark Continent
however he has up until recently being
unable to secure any of the required
conditions to make this a reality so
already we can now see that Jing and
parastone were on a second collision
course and as such after the election
they both resigned from their positions
as zodiacs within the Association in
order to pursue their oddly shared goal
however ultimately it would be another
figure that would come to facilitate
their involvement in current events who
is a man by the name of beyond natterer
now if you're familiar with some of my
other hunter hunter videos like the
succession will recap or the one
recounting everything we know about the
Dark Continent then you'll know what
beyond general deal is basically he
aligned himself with the cocking Empire
and offered to act as their guide to
settle on the Dark Continent because
beyond has as of right now an
undisclosed ambition on the landmass
what I haven't gone into much detail
about in those videos though is that
beyond is not acting alone
and he has assembled his own separate
expedition team that he plans on joining
upon breaking out of his confinement by
the hunter Association at some stage
whether that be aboard the black whale 1
well once they reach the dark continent
itself regardless in beyonds absence
there was a number 2 within the
expedition team and that
second-in-command just so happened to be
one para Stan hill now once again his
motives behind devoting a staggering
amount of time and resources to
cultivating beyonds organization is
unknown but the ever resourceful Jing
was able to discover this group and
casually stroll into their hideout
asking to become part of their
expedition team now of course we do know
that jinx greatest desire at this point
in time does seem to be to travel to the
Dark Continent
but in this situation his actions also
came with a side dish of a somewhat more
noble purpose as he demonstrated concern
for what Paris did may do to the hunter
Association so in order to take
Barristan
focus off them Jing essentially offers
himself claiming that he will play with
parastone personally from now on until
he begs him to stop although Jing said
it much less sexually suggestive than I
probably made it sound but this
statement is effectively the beginning
of a brand new chess match between the
two except on a significantly more
serious scale as Paris Tonasket if this
meant that Jing was finally going to pay
attention to him at this point Jing also
reveals that he is well aware of the
fact that Paris did manage to acquire
5,000 chimera and cocoons bowling Isaac
metros death in his quarter cocoons that
have more than likely hatched by now
into 5,000 chimera ants each equipped
with the ability to use nen effectively
putting Paris Tintin command of one of
if not the most fearsome army that the
human realm has ever known however this
is Paris tan we're talking about so it's
very unlikely that he'd be using this
power for a typical bad guy purpose and
in fact the ideas floated by Jing was
that he may potentially use them to
either infiltrate the hunter Association
by taking the exam which given their
natural abilities as well as Paris tans
tutelage they would have been guaranteed
to pass on mass although Jing then goes
on to admit that he has no idea exactly
what Paris turn would do with an
association full of ants but hey the
option is there another idea that was
posed was that Paris too may choose to
unleash his army upon the world in order
to hurt the reputation of the hunter
Association and in doing so force a
policy change in regards to travel to
the belt constant in any case at this
point other members of the expedition
team weren't taking so kindly to Jing
qu's intrusion but he quickly pulled him
in their place and went on to make
assumptions of who the leader of the
group was based on the strength of the
aura that he could sense in the room and
this led powerstone to announcing his
position as second-in-command as well as
stating that Jing and underestimated him
but Jing of course knew better than this
making the claim that if power stone was
all about brute force and he would have
settled this by now and simply pummeled
him instead Jing admitted that power
stone was far far more trouble than a
purely powerful individual and insisted
that in order to defeat him then he
would have to break his spirit the
notion which Paris 10 cm to take a
degree of delight in hearing and a step
one in operation break the spirit of
Harriston hill Jing boldly claimed that
despite the fact that he had only just
rocked up out of nowhere he was now the
second-in-command of the group right
behind beyond which is a really weird
statement to say actually right behind
beyond
behind beyond now obviously this caused
an immediate uproar amongst the
expedition team with two of its members
immediately preparing to engage
in combat however Jing diffused the
situation by making a very tempting
offer
essentially Jing proposed that he would
pay each member of the team twice what
Beyond was offering them and not only
that he would pay the amount upfront
with no questions asked or stipulating
conditions other than the fact that he'd
be recognized as the second in charge of
the team to add to this Jing even made
it clear that the team were free to keep
doing exactly what Paris tanto them -
meaning that he was more or less giving
up a small nation's GDP worth of money
but the superficial right to be
considered as a higher standing than
Paris tone I mean as always that's not
all there was to it be no one-upping
Barristan is always a nice bonus
in reality though one of the team's
members immediately saw this as a plot
by Jing to remove individuals who were
less than profoundly motivated to visit
the Dark Continent and it seemed to
actually work in one case as a member
promptly provided his bank account
details receive the money and then
immediately and politely excused himself
from the compound never to be seen again
also we thought because that particular
individual did return later after using
the money to pay off some debt of a
hospital that his sister was being
perpetually treated at now of course you
would think the parastone would be at
least mildly annoyed by this development
but to the contrary he openly embraced
the idea of Jing becoming second in
command praising it as a great idea in
his terrifyingly optimistic parastone
way and in fact as he was a member of
the team Jing even offered to double
Parsons fee as well however he also
correctly deduced the power Aston was
not being paid to learn to take this
mission and stated that two times zero
would still equal zero adding further
intrigued Parsons personal motives
behind this mission Jing then went on to
share his knowledge of the Dark
Continent with the group including the
tales of past expeditions that each
brought one of the five threats back to
the human realm the elusive and
world-changing items at the voyages were
seeking and most tantalizingly the only
book ever written by an explorer of the
continent named journey to the new world
east edition authored by a man named Don
freaks now given that this team had been
preparing for this mission for quite
some time it was a bit of a shock that
none of them really knew any of this
information beforehand and the beyond
had not quite informed them of exactly
how high-risk the mission would be the
only exception to this was of course
parastone whose access to knowledge
undoubtedly would have led him to be
privy to most of if not everything Jing
revealed furthermore shortly parastone
was going to feel something brand new
which was a feeling approaching hatred
for another human being this is very
relevant because throughout his in
highlife Harriston who focused on
garnering the hatred of others had never
truly felt that way about someone else
although it should be said that he had
always felt compelled to hurt those who
were dear to him and so as Jing
correctly deduced more and more about
the organization including the fact that
everyone present was an expert in some
sort of field necessary for survival on
the continent as well as their true
numbers Harriston began to feel annoyed
very annoyed even Harriston then
silently hypothesized that perhaps the
reason why he didn't like Jing was
because they think so alike and propose
that he may even grow to hate this man
but that wasn't a bad feeling at all for
parastone on the contrary it made him
exceptionally excited because knowing
the way he treats thinks he loves
Harriston was practically frothing at
the mouth to have the opportunity to see
exactly what he would do to someone that
he truly hates and at this point in the
story we have a one-month time-skip
and surprisingly afterwards Jing and
parastone are still on superficially
friendly terms even after spending four
weeks in close proximity to each other
that was about to change though because
parastone had concocted a plan to
attempt to discover what jinx known
abilities were in order to begin
properly plotting against him and this
took the form of ordering some of IANS
team to attempt to kill both of them
although Jing easily saw through this
plan and defeated the henchmen using a
hot suit that he had copied from the
area known as a remote punch now well
Virginia explained that his power to
imitate the abilities of others was
merely a natural talent appears and the
de perak stand on today his real ability
then he would have to face off against
him himself and that is sadly where we
have left these two in the series as it
stands at the time of this recording
what I will say is that despite the fact
that the Blackwell one has left carrying
seemingly all of those who are bound for
the Dark Continent
there has been no confirmation on
whether or not Jing or parastone are
aboard or if they are headed to the
continent via an alternate means I would
say that the latter is unlikely just
because of how absurdly difficult it is
to source a vessel and the crew for such
a trip but then again this group of
experts has been preparing this for
quite some time so it's not out of the
question at all but what we do know for
sure is that things are only going to
become more and more intense for
parastone and Jing as the Dark Continent
story unfolds a proper clash to settle
this rivalry whether it be physical or
mental is imminent and I would be
shocked if both of them left the Dark
Continent unfazed
or even if both of them left at all but
that pretty much does it for this short
recap of Zhi embarrassed
involvement in the current storyline if
you enjoyed this video and the content
this channel produced in general then
please do consider donating to the new
world review patreon because the support
of all of your amazing people is what
continues to make this channel possible
and if patreon isn't quite your style
then please do leave this video a like
share or subscribe because it also helps
for this channel an incredible amount
and if you'd like to join the fun at any
time then please do head over to my
discord server where a wide array of
shenanigan takes place on a daily basis
and finally please do comment with your
thoughts on Jing Harrison and the Dark
Continent this has been the new world
review and I'll see you next time
[Music]
you